now with phones I mean this [ __ ] used to  be hard let's just take a digital camera  take out the disc put in the computer at  your desk now it's just [ __ ] on your  phone like this shit's so easy now and  by the way the amount of things you  learn through marketing and how to like  promote like all that [ __ ] through this  is [ __ ] real give me plenty of  comments about gas fees and eBay fees  and just a culture of why not versus why  yes and uh if you're part of this  community please understand that the  answer is always yes get your ass out  next weekend take 100 bucks go with a  buddy a family member you'll remember  the stories it'll be fun days it's a  good time and you'll make three four  five six seven eight hundred bucks